[Music]
brad's in ohio hey brad welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey how's it going dave i appreciate you
uh you and dr bologna having me on
sure how can we help well my question is
in regards to
um i guess red flags or kind of pitfalls
you can fall into
uh when you're looking for you know a
partner or a spouse
or just dating in general i mean i'm 28
years old i just recently moved to ohio
took a 30
pay increase and um you know made the
decision to uh
to live with my sister and
brother-in-law in their basement so i
could pay off uh
my debt and i've paid gone from 50 000
in debt to 30 000 now
good for you in the course of four
months yeah so uh but i'm starting to
date and uh
you know aside from from living in my
sister's basement
that's a great first line right hey
what's up i'm brad
i live in my sister's basement
now i know i know you're probably going
to tell me that you know the right
the right uh person would understand the
right woman would understand the
situation and be
you know more than accommodating but in
general what are some what are some
things to look out for
because i don't want to fall into one of
those circumstances like you guys were
just discussing
where you know i'm a statistic where uh
bankruptcy leads to divorce and
so on and so forth so are there any
indicators early on in a relationship
when you first start dating
um that could you know could provide
some insight and
you know where you could could not fall
into that pitfall dr
john hmm i would quote our good friend
henry cloud on that which is when
somebody
decides they are all in on you somebody
decides they want to get to know you
they have a picture of you in their life
and that can be after one day in two
days it doesn't mean you go get married
but they start
saying i want to be with this person
there's not games
and there's not shenanigans and there's
not hoops and trials
there is a genuine desire to get
to be connected with somebody to learn
about them to be with them
not over them not about them but for
them and
um so i i always i'm not one that
believes there's one person for
everybody i think
it to have a good marriage you wake up
every day and decide i'm gonna love this
person with all i got
and i'm gonna do the best i can with
tools i got today when i screw up i'm
gonna say i'm sorry
and that marriage is a daily decision
that i'm going to love i'm going to love
i'm going to love
and so i think for you you have to list
out with what the values are who you're
looking for
what you want to be a part of and then
you've got to
um work as hard as you can to be for
somebody
and i would suggest that before for you
and and once it does get serious i'd
spend some time in pre-marriage
counseling there's a lot of
uh statistical data that says a good
in-depth
pre-marriage counseling is highly
correlated with success on marriage
and because it forces you to look at
what we call the four things that are
out there
and if you look if you can find out that
you're largely in agreement on these
four areas you've got a good shot and
that's money
in religion and kids
if you can if you can be largely in
agreement on those four things
you're gonna go a long way and uh lastly
i've heard it said that if she says
she's not crazy it usually means she is
to move on
that's at the point brad when you tell
her you live in your sister's basement
and that will clear itself up i'm not
crazy
i'm not crazy oh good i'm glad next date